hey what's up yep I'm doing a podcast
late to the party but whatever I'm out
in Nashville John shows so I just
brought my news room I got the equipment
using them my laptop as the camera for
now just cuz I'm not here I just wanted
to make an announcement yellow I'm doing
a podcast you gonna get a real world
advice from a grown-ass man just news
and notes it's just my perspective
stories things that are going on in my
life and I'll have a few gifts not a lot
but I know a lot of great people and
I've already asked around so let me get
some great people on my show I don't
know what to say you know it's like damn
podcast world is like is there enough
podcast that probably are so is there
room for one more
they better beat is gonna be me so look
out for me coming soon whippin with
written written with Whitney coming your
way working title